Intel has been the biggest name in processor
production for many, many years, but recently,
they’ve started to lose the race to not
only their main rival, AMD, but to some new
names in the game like Qualcomm, Samsung,
and even Apple.
While there’s a lot that’s happened over
the years that we can’t get into a short
video like this, let’s quickly go through
some history of Intel’s battle with AMD
for the PC market.
For many years, AMD CPUs were once seen as
inferior compared to Intel’s CPUs, so they
started investing their resources trying to
catch up, while building their own tech into
their CPUs.
And in 2003, AMD released their heavy-hitter
Athlon 64-bit CPUs, which for the first time,
were superior to Intel’s offerings at the
time, with AMD putting a big focus on gaming.
Intel rushed to catch up on 64-bit CPUs, and
it wasn’t until 2006 when they released
their Core 2 Duo processor, their first dual-core
processors that destroyed the mainstream CPUs
AMD was offering.
And shortly after, AMD starting producing
their Athlon X2 dual-core processors, and
then they both ventured into quad-core and
beyond.
And while all of this was happening, PC gaming
was starting to get really popular, and a
lot of gaming had to decide between a mainstream
Intel processor, or a more budget friendly
AMD CPU.
Being in my early teens and huge into gaming
back then, I went with AMD’s Phenom 2 955
Black-edition quad-core processor that I was
able to overclock and run some of my favorite
games.
And while AMD was focusing on putting out
more cores, Intel decided to mostly stick
with quad-core processors for many years,
enjoying the bulk of the market share, and
providing a wide-range of processors for companies
like Apple, from low-end laptop chips to high-end
Xeon server chips.
Enjoying their success, they weren’t really
investing much into new technology or putting
out impressive spec bumps with each new processor,
since they didn’t really have to worry about
the competition too much.
In the meantime, there was some new players
entering the game.
In 2011, ARM Holdings announced their first
64-bit mobile chips and in 2013, Apple announced
the iPhone 5S, the first 64-bit smartphone
packing their own A7 chip.
And with smartphones becoming increasingly
more popular, Apple and Android smartphone
makers continued the fight to create the fastest
mobile processors for our phones, but no one
was expecting mobile chip performance to grow
so quickly.
We’ll dig deeper into that in just a minute.
With AMD being the runner-up to Intel, they
never stopped pushing for newer tech that
could finally disrupt Intel’s market-share
streak, and in 2017, this happened:
AMD released their first line of Ryzen 7 processors,
offering very impressive performance for much
less cash than Intel’s competing chips.
While this was happening, Intel was already
in trouble, having a very hard time moving
to their 10nm process.
In fact, in 2013, Intel claimed it could produce
10nm chips by 2015.
Then they changed it to 2016, and then late
2017, and then late 2019, and here we are
in 2019, and we’re finally seeing some mainstream
10nm chips, which I’ll get into in a moment.
So what was Intel’s response to AMD announcing
Ryzen?
They brought hyper-threading to their i5 and
continued to squeeze out every bit of performance
they could out of their 14nm process while
beginning to finally lower their prices to
be able to compete with AMD.
And at the same time, AMD was going full force
with their Ryzen and Threadripper processors,
continuing to improve performance while reducing
processor cost compared to Intel’s offerings.
In 2018, AMD was the best-performing stock
on the S&P 500, and in the past year, it’s
basically doubled in value, gaining a lot
of attention from mass media and consumers.
Around a month ago AMD revealed the specs
of their upcoming 7nm Zen 2 processors at
Computex 2019, with performance that completely
destroys everything that Intel has to offer,
while using less power and being priced lower.
And just a few days ago, the world's-first
7nm Zen 2 desktop CPUs from AMD are now available
for purchase.
And they’ve also released very competitive
products in both the mobile APU chip market
and graphics card market as well.
Shortly after that, an internal Intel memo
was leaked, admitting that AMD’s new Zen
2 processors will offer great performance
results with prices that are significantly
below Intel’s, offering good performance-per-dollar.
However, Intel also announced their new 10nm
Ice Lake processors at Computex 2019, and
they’re packing more performance and a lot
of new technology, like integrated Thunderbolt
3.
Their 10nm chips are coming to thin laptops
and tablets first, like Dell’s 2019 XPS
13 2-in-1, which should be coming soon.
Unfortunately, it may already be too late
for Intel.
They’ve been behind for a couple of years
now, giving AMD a chance to swipe up some
market share, especially since Intel processors
have been experiencing some major security
issues with the recent Spectre and meltdown
vulnerabilities.
Intel’s going to have to come back strong
in the years to come to compete with AMD,
but I haven’t even talked about their relationship
with Apple, and how they could be losing their
business very soon.
As many of you may know, Apple’s MacBook
Pros have been experiencing thermal issues
in recent years, and here’s why.
While Intel was promising that their more
efficient 10nm processors would be coming
soon, Apple was working on their 2016 redesign
of the MacBook Pro, making it as thin as they
could possibly make it while packing awesome
performance.
Unfortunately, Intel’s 10nm processors weren’t
ready for the initial 2016 release of the
MacBook Pro, so Apple had to stick with Intel’s
old 14nm processors, which was fine for the
time being, but Apple and their MacBook Pros
thin and very limited cooling system weren’t
expecting Intel to delay 10nm for so long.
And when Intel started to increase core count
to keep up with AMD’s Ryzen processors,
the MacBook Pro started to throttle, really
bad, especially with last years’ Intel’s
6-core i9 processor.
This has caused Apple some very bad press
coverage, pushing users to believe that the
MacBook Pro can’t handle the heat of Intel’s
latest processors.
In the meantime, Apple’s mobile ARM chips
have been getting faster and faster every
single year, especially with the release of
their 2018 iPad Pro, packing their A12X processor,
which packed performance that surpassed 92%
of all laptops, tablets and convertible PCs
sold before its release.
So the question a lot of people have is: Why
not just switch to these ARM processors and
ditch Intel?
Well, that’s exactly what Apple’s been
working on.
They started the process by creating their
T2 chip, which takes over a lot of processes
that the Intel processor used to do, and they’ve
been working on making it easier to port iOS
software over to Mac, which will in-turn make
it easier for an ARM processor to run macOS.
The biggest challenge will be getting Thunderbolt
3 working with an ARM processor, but just
a few months ago, Apple hired a leading ARM
chip engineer to help them make the switch.
When this happens, it’ll become cheaper
for Apple to produce their Macs, and Intel
will slowly start to lose Apple’s business.
And that’s not the worst part, other companies
will follow in Apple’s footsteps and start
replacing Intel processors with ARM chips.
Their only chance will be to step up their
game and make processors that can compete
with AMD and these up-and-coming powerful
ARM chips.
If you enjoyed this video, make sure to tap
the like button and click the circle above
to subscribe.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video!